hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game from yesterday's
candidates tournament uh it's round nine
and it's kiril alexander vs alexander
grishock uh quite an ex
exhausting game uh so better uh just
dive straight into it carol still
without a win in this tournament and
grishok still looking for his chances to
catch up to the
uh to the leaders uh so let's see let's
see what happened here uh alexenko with
the white pieces opens with
e4 uh sorry about that uh and if you
haven't seen the
uh yesterday's video do check it out as
it was also a very very
uh it it's a game you don't want to miss
uh so e4 we have e6 the grisha goes for
the
uh french defense with d4 d5 and now
knight the c3
whoa d5 and knight to c3 uh we have
knight to f6
and e5 now going for the stein its
variation we advance the pawn kick away
the knight
so knight uh after d7 and now as black
is uh expected to attack the center with
c5 we further defend our center with
f4 and while doing so grab more space so
c5 attacking the center here and the
knight to f3 with knight to c6 and
bishop to e3
going for the boleslavsky variation this
is all very standard
stuff thousands of games in this exact
same variation
and here black has a lot of very popular
options queen to b6 being one of them
the
e7 a6 so all very very much playable
stuff
but here for this game gurishu goes for
c captures on d4
trading in the center right away we have
knight captures and now
queen to b6 developing the queen to b6
now putting pressure
on the center also the knight now cannot
move because the queen captures an e3
would come with
check and also the b2 pawn is under
attack and here alexenko says no problem
just queen to d2 and here uh grishok has
the option of capturing
the b2 pawn or not capturing the b2 pawn
but if you already play
this line you go after this pawn that's
how this line is played
and it's very interesting to see maxine
couldn't hold on to his b2 pawn can
grishok hold on to his b2 pawn so here
he grabs it with queen captures on b2
rook to b1 and now queen to a3 getting
the queen out of the way and now
bishop to b5 so white getting a lot of
development in for that pawn
but it is uh it is expected that white
will
win it back very quickly so here knight
captures on d4
uh bishop captures and just a6 uh
forcing the bishop to move uh here we
have bishop captures on these seven
bishop captures
and now rook to b3 kicking the queen
back now you could also
play rook to b3 before trading on d7
this has also been played
but for sorry about that
oh
sorry about that it was the mailman uh
it's like they know when
when i start recording so rook to b3
like i said it can be played before the
trade on d7 but
uh uh here uh alexenko does it
afterwards
uh we have queen back to e7 and now uh
rook
captures on b7 and this is nothing new
this has all been played before looks
very scary but black is perfectly happy
playing this
queen to h4 with check now you can
either block with the g3 but
then it you kind of weaken your position
a bit too much so here queen to f2
and good issue trades we have capture
sun f2 king captures and now
bishop to a7 for the moment you don't
really have the option of castling
because
well your light square bishop is hanging
but you are playing some
preparing some bishop to d8 bishop to c6
and then the bishop pair will uh
get get rid of that uh uh white rook
uh and here rook uh h the uh b1
is uh one known move that has been
played in one game
but here we have knight to d1 and it is
now
as of move 18 that we have a completely
new game
uh so let's see how good he should deals
with it so basically you want to play
knight to e3 and this will uh grant you
support for pushing c4 and you will
attack black's very strong center so
this is the idea alexenko has here
and he's basically playing on uh on
some better development than some better
piece pieces position
positioning uh because if you know the
the position opens up it is
definitely grisha who still has the
bishop pair so here we have bishop to d8
preparing that bishop to c6 to get
the rook away from such an active uh
position we have knight to e3
continuing with his plan of executing c4
and bishop to c6 now so the rook now
must
leave we have rooked a b2 and now
finally uh
grishok is able to castle so kingside
castles
uh we have bishop to c5 now uh
attacking rook but basically just
re-maneuvering the bishop we rook the e8
and
only now uh do we strike in the center
with c4
so what do you do here well f6 you
undermine white's
center we have c captures on the e5 e
captures on d5
this has created a past pawn for grishik
also
and the bishop to d6 now so here black
will have some problems of getting those
rooks into the game
as the da file cannot be used for rooks
uh the the b
file is now absolutely under white's
control
so it will take some time for black to
get those rooks into the game so here we
have calculus captures
and d4 now uh the d5 pawn is
kind of weak now you can very easily
attack it here so grishok needs to
advance it with d4
attacking the knight knight to f5 and
now even d3
the pawn will be nicely defended when
the bishop comes to b5
king to e3 attacking that pawn and
bishop to b5 now
so how can alexenko push for something
here we have
king the e4 a very nice attacking move
uh with the king
we have rooked the c8 grishok finally
gets his rook to a nice open c file
and knight to d4 now uh white would very
much enjoy
eliminating one of black's bishops so
grisham needs to do something about this
bishop the c4 is played
and now rook to d1 uh at some point
white might even have plans of giving up
uh
the the exchange here with real captures
and d3 but it is much too early for such
things first a5 by grishok we have
a3 and now g6 uh
just uh improving the position a little
bit but also weakening the seventh rank
so
uh alexenko immediately brings the rook
over to b7
and now bishop to f6 shifting the bishop
over to g7 of course the
the pawn is pinned you cannot do
anything about this we have knight to f3
and now bishop to g7 we broke the a7
going after the pawn here
and just rook c to d8 now uh sort of a
little trick
if of course you captured the pawn then
the bishop is for free the pawn is
pinned you you will not be able to
capture it
so here king to d4 by aleksenko and now
uh grishok needs to needs to find a move
here he need he basically
only needs to find a way how to activate
his rooks because his bishop pair
is doing all right but the rooks not so
much and here
a move like rook captures on d6 might be
an interesting one basically
you just eliminated this piece of course
the rook cannot be captured but white
will capture this
and now we could go into a very very uh
tricky line of
rook the c8 check king to b3 rook the b6
check king to a4 and now rook to c for
with
with check we give up a pawn here and
now rook to b3 and it could be very
dangerous for the white king here
if knight to d2 going after the rooks we
do not want to capture this pawn we just
want to
keep the king uh stuck here on the a
file so rook c5 check for example king
tay for now rook b8
keeps the the king here on the a file
and now if we could activate our dark
square bishop somehow
could be some very very uh interesting
mating
ideas uh here uh but okay grisha goes
for some
uh something different after king d4 he
just moves the bishop bishop to b3
and it makes sense now there is no
target on c4 you
move the bishop with tempo and now rook
captures uh bishop is definitely still a
threat because this is impossible
and it doesn't seem like you have all
that much you can do here
for example if you just move the bishop
rook to b1 uh it doesn't really matter
just rook captures on d6 with check and
now whatever you do doesn't really work
if if king to c3 we can just bring the
bishop back so that
obviously doesn't work and if you try
something like king to c5
not much better we're just going to play
rook d5 check king c6
and then just for example d2 if you
capture the bishop d1 queen
uh and so on so not an easy decision for
aleksanko here but
he had all of this planned out so here
he just goes for it
rook captures on g7 with check
uh girisha of course has to capture and
now comes to rook
captures on d3 uh this was his idea
uh and uh now well now grishok has uh
is uh uh up the exchange but his rooks
still not very active so he needs the
he needs to try and activate himself
somehow first a4
uh that the bishop and porn are now uh
nicely defending each other
and uh alexenko will need to figure out
how to how to do something about this so
here knights to d2
ready to capture and now bishop back to
e6
uh interesting well rather interesting
was bishop to c2
uh and uh and if rook to c3 then rook to
c8
we definitely want to trade off a pair
of rooks here but then for example
knight to c4
we go bishop d1 and the game continues
it's all very very
uh interesting and this bishop pawn
barrier here
is just very hard to deal with even
though you have two rooks
so after knight d2 we have bishop back
to e6 and
now comes knight to e4 now this point
this knight is coming to c5 and it's
going to be
well just going to be a very strong
piece here so here bishop to f5
uh girisha says all right that knight
isn't going anywhere we're going to
eliminate it as soon as possible
so rook to e3 and now bishop captures on
e4 we have rook captures and rook to f8
and here gurishak says
all right we've traded everything off
now you you still have the knight bishop
and pawn here in the center but i'm
gonna use these open files to get my
rooks into the game
if i can play rook f2 it's basically
game over so of course alexenko stops
this he plays king to e3
uh and uh rook f back to e8
asking okay what what do you what are
you gonna do now
uh we have rook to f rook uh we have
king to f4
and now rook to a8 just defending that
a4 pawn we have rook to b4
and now comes rook to a7 not allowing
any checks along the seventh rank we
have king to e4
and now king to f7 by grisha we have
rook to b6
uh grabbing more space and now rook to
c8
so now you will try to go after the
pawns this way
so here just bishop to b4 uh very
interesting here is e6 although it
doesn't do all that much you can't
capture the pawn because this just wins
material
but you don't have to capture the pawn
you can just move your king and that's
it for example
king to g8 and it doesn't seem to be
like there's uh
well all that all that much you can do
here uh you're never getting this pawn
to to this light square because uh well
black has two rooks and you can easily
defend the lights where white only has
the dark square bishops are not going to
help out
with the the the queening of the pawn uh
but okay after rook the c8 we have
bishop to b4
uh and now comes uh rook a to c7
now interestingly if you go for some uh
rook to c2 action here
uh then the rook left uh the the back
rank and the d8 square is no longer
defended so e6 could be a little bit
dangerous here so grisha is still not
ready to commit to this
we have rook eight to c7 now doubling up
on the c file
and now this row can come to c2 while
this rook can remain here regarding the
back rank
and now king to d5 alexenko says i no
longer care about the back rank i now go
go in uh well basically go going all in
so rook to c2 going after the the king
side pawns now
e6 with check king f6 and now rook to b7
with some ideas of
rook to f7 check which could be deadly
uh for example if you play something
like
h5 we just play rook f7 check and after
something like this just uh
e7 and it's very hard to to deal with
this white
white will definitely win this rook the
f8 is coming
uh you cannot deliver any checks the
bishop very nicely controls this so it's
uh
well it's bad news so here and grisha
goes for g5 instead now this is a little
bit different
uh and now comes well now now you're
you can also capture the h7 pawn uh rook
the f7 check here
not so great because now the king can
come to g6 and it's uh
well now it's different now you can
never push the pawn the rook will be
under attack so
uh very important uh square for the
black king so instead after g5 we have
rook captures on h7
and now comes rook captures on g2
you could also try some rook the d8
check ideas maybe to get
the the white king away but then you can
just block rook to
rook to d7 and it doesn't do all that
much for example rook to
rook to e8 we're gonna play rook to f7
check king to g6 now we're gonna go
back rook to a7 go after the a4 pawn and
if not rook captures on g2 we're gonna
play king to d6
so it's a very very very very hard to
play this rook to e2 you have to cover
that uh
pawn otherwise king the d7 is just
winning and now we're going to play e7
and it's basically
basically a draw but you know it's
always a draw
this is the candidate tournament every
position is a draw until it's not
uh so one of the possibilities
definitely but here instead we have rook
captures on g2 grisha grabs the pawn
right away
now king the d6 again ready to push that
pawn we've kinked the g6
pushing the rook back and now rook to h3
still keeping an eye on the h2 pawn
we have g for now uh rook the e3
and now comes rook captures on h2
finally we have king to d7
now attacking the rook ready to push the
pawn and rook h to h8 now
like we said we have to keep an eye on
the e8 that is a light square
we have e7 and now comes rook c
to e8 uh king f5 also a possibility here
you might still be in time to
maybe get get your king deeper into the
position start pushing that pawn
uh but grisha goes to rook c to e8
instead and here grishok adopted this
well rook maneuvering technique and
while magnus was commenting on this on
the live stream he said that
maybe grishok adopted this technique of
maybe just moving the rooks
along the back rank in order to get
aleksanenko to play for a win
and then look for his chances but it's a
it's a very
dangerous strategy so here bishop the d6
by alexenko
uh and now comes rook back to a8 now
just defending the a4 pawn once again
and here we have bishop to c7
uh interestingly if you go uh for pawn
promotion here
uh not really not really all that great
because after brook captures we're gonna
play rook captures and if rook captures
and king captures
now we're gonna get king to f5 but uh if
king to d7 for example uh we're gonna
get king to e4 now king to c6
and now king back to f5 you you never
want to play this and try to push this
pawn because the white king is just too
fast he's gonna pick up this pawn
and then queen this pawn so you'd have
to go king f5 and then if king b5 we go
king to e6
and this is how we uh save the game
because after the bishop moves it
doesn't really matter where you're going
to play king d7
and it only matters for the black king
to reach the a8
this is a light square and it doesn't
matter if you lose both of these pawns
uh
there's only uh well uh a dark square
bishop and uh
a pawn on the a file and it's of course
a light square against the dark square
bishop
the black king will be able to draw this
if he reaches the corner
so uh a bit too soon for this alexandros
still wants to keep uh
chances alive so he goes bishop to c7
now
rook ate the g8 by grishok again just
re-maneuvering his
rooks we have rook to e4 uh with with an
attack on the pawns
and now king to f5 defending the spawn
and now comes
uh rook to f4 with check you might be
thinking why not rook captures an a4
well then we go into this g3 line and
it's not much
for example bishop to f4 check king g6
rook to e4
and now we're gonna go g2 and now after
bishop to b6 guarding the queening
square
we go into some very very cool lines
king to f5 attacks the rook rook to e2
and now finally g1 queen we're going to
play bishop captures on g1
rook captures and g1 and now e8 queen uh
we're going to go
captures captures and now rook to a1 and
of course this is a well-known drawn
position even though white is up upon
doesn't really matter
so after king to f5 uh alexinko says
nope it's still much too early to grab
this pawn rook to f4 with
check we have king to g5 and only now
rook captures on a4
and now the king is kind of blocking the
g pawn so you don't really have the
option of pushing it so here
king the h4 by grishok and now comes uh
well now comes uh
rook the e4 a very interesting idea is
bishop to d6 with the idea of maybe rook
to f4
at the f8 but then rook to h7 and uh
it's it's very hard to decipher what is
going on here
but it is definitely a possibility this
bishop to b6 move alexenko
goes for a different line he goes rook
to e4 and now uh grisha
retreats with rook to a8 but now it's
different uh now that the rook moved to
a4 both a4 and a5 are covered and now
alexandra
can just push his past pawn so a5 now
the a pawn also becomes a
you know a problem and now grisha
has to go back king to g5 problem is if
you go king to h3
then you get this a5 move g3 and now e8
queen and we get basically a very
similar uh uh
idea of what we've already shown uh
captures captures uh and then after
everything gets traded off here on the e
file we're gonna play g2 but now bishop
to b6
saves the day so white just wins here so
instead after a4 we have king to g5
grisha needs to go back and
now a5 like we said this is protected
and now you have problem
uh because now king comes here the the
rook is under attack you're going to
have to move the rook away
and then well for example king from b7
covers all of these three squares
could be a problem so rook to h7
and now king to c6 unpinning now
uh you will be able to play some like
bishop to d8 to block the queening
square
so rook h back to h8 and now king back
to d7 here we have a repetition of moves
but of course alexenko is still not
ready to call it a draw
uh he still needs to be pushing so rook
h2h8
and now rook to e3 uh for king to b7
even though it looks very appealing
is a bit too soon because here we're
gonna go g3
a6 g2 and now uh for example rook to e1
guarding that g1 square now we're gonna
play rook eight to eight
uh and now comes a7 uh so here we're
gonna play rook to h1
and now comes a really really cool
series of moves a8
queen rook captures an a8 and now
bishop to d8 blocking the queening
square from the rook and also preparing
queening with
a discovery here so here we're going to
play rook captures on e1
now covering the queening square but it
doesn't matter e8 with
check from the bishop rook captures
queen captures and now king to g4 and
this is a draw because
well uh you still have a rook and the
pawn that's ready to queen
and the black will simply not uh be able
to get out of checks but a really really
really cool line so after this we have
ripped the e3
alekseenko still not rushing it would
move like king to b7
and now rook h the e8 the gurishu again
shifts the rook
along the eighth rank king to d7 but now
it's much different because if you go
rook to h8 now then just
e8 queen and that's it for example
captures captures and then it doesn't
matter you either trade here and then of
course we can still stop the
the g pawn with the bishop or if you go
rook to a6 it doesn't really matter
you're just gonna play rook g8 to check
and you are never
crossing that g3 square with the pawn
it's just winning for white
so after king d7 we have king to f6 by
grishok
and now rook to e6 with check we have
king to f7 and now
rook back to e4 we have king f6 grishok
of course uh hoping for a repetition
here but now
bishop to d8 and there isn't much
uh you can do here the rook is under
attack so here if you move it to just e8
queen
wins the game obviously you have to yeah
it's it's a discovery from the bishop so
you don't really have uh
an option of capturing the queen so you
have to go for captures king captures
now rook captures rogue captures and of
course this is not winning for white
uh you will easily sacrifice this rook
for the pawn and you will queen your own
pawn
so after bishop 28 grisha has one last
attempt king f5 but now just
king capture 78 king capture sunny for n
king to f8 and he was in this position
on move 74 that alexander geshok
resigned the game
as there was nothing more to be done
here uh whatever you play let's say g3
and just e8 queen comes with
check and that's just it so really an
amazing game and it's uh
it's beyond impressive how alexinko held
his own against uh against uh a monster
player like
like sasha here and uh he really was not
interested in the draw he just kept
pushing kept pushing kept looking for
chances
and maybe it maybe it does all come down
to this that magnus said uh that
maybe uh maybe grishok was just uh you
know moving his rooks along the back
ranked uh to kind of get alexenko to
play for a win
uh but uh you know uh you know what they
say be careful
what you wish for here maybe alexander
wished for that
and alex sanko definitely went for the
win and he did win it
so really really impressive stuff first
the win for alexenko
yeah in the uh fide 2021 or rather 20 20
20 21 candidates tournament so
very very nice for that congratulations
and also
let us not uh miss out on the standings
so here are the standings
it's a bit sorry it's a bit large let me
just
downsize this it's from chess 24 so
there you go uh all right
there we go so after uh round eight
uh we had two decisive games the one
that we've shown fabiano corona
versus the maximum sheila graph and this
one kilo axilenco alexenko vs alexander
grishock and these are the standings
after round eight
so yanipong she's still leading because
he was the leader going into round eight
and he was able to draw his game
uh followed by uh fabiano corona who won
his game against maxime bashar lagrave
then we have anish giri and van gaal
with four
uh a nice 50 percent uh alexenko and
grishok with three and a half and the
ding lyran
still with with three points uh so in
last place
but he did uh give well sort of a
crippling blow to fabiana corona as he
did
defeat him uh in the first half of the
candidates tournament
uh so that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it we're going to continue
covering the candidates tournament then
maybe i see you guys are suggesting a
lot of games uh so i will
see if i will have time to cover those
but uh mostly
we'll be sticking to the candidates
tournament uh
uh well until the end because these are
kind of important games for
for the chess world so yeah i would like
to thank philip gleason uh mr hoody guy
robert smith pablo mohan and patrick
solarz for contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the
candidates tournament checking up on
your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day